Nike rewards Colin Kaepernick for
kneeling judge Brett Kavanaugh has his
day before the Senate and as president
Trump's tweets gain volume anti-trump
commentators used John McCain's funeral
to slam the president I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show well the
news cycle just keeps on going doesn't
matter that you took the weekend off the
news did not take the weekend off and so
we are back here to review all of it
with you and we'll go through all of it
in just one second but first let me
remind you that our national debt is
twenty one trillion dollars in counting
that is greater than the entire economic
output of the United States if your
entire life savings is tied to the US
dollar should ask yourself this what
happens if the government says to
inflate its way out of debt hedge
against inflation hedge against
uncertainty and instability with
precious metals gold is indeed a safe
haven against uncertainty my savings
plan is diversified and yours should be
as well the company I trust with
precious metals purchases is as you know
Birch gold group and right now thanks to
a little-known IRS tax law you can even
move that IRA or eligible 401k into an
IRA backed by physical gold and silver
which is perfect for some who want to
protect their hard-earned retirement
savings from future geopolitical
uncertainty when you look back
historically what you see is when the
bottom falls out of everything else gold
tends to safeguard savings Birch gold
group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau so the question you should be
asking yourself is what is your plan for
diversification you all know about Birch
Gold's free information kit
but for a limited time qualified
purchases can earn up to an additional
10 grand and precious metals for free
through September 30th to find out if
your purchase will qualify contact Birch
gold now go to Birch gold calm / Ben
talk to Birch gold rep mention I say you
ask all your questions and then when you
have all your answers invest with
birchgold.com / Ben right now the offer
runs until September 30th terms of
limitations to apply ask their sales
representatives for details all right so
we begin today with Nike so actually you
know what let's not be given Mikey
screw that let's start with the let's
started the judicial hearing so this
morning Brett Kavanaugh who's the the
judge who's now being appointed by
President Trump to the Supreme Court of
the United States was scheduled to have
his opening hearing at the Senate
Judiciary Committee now all of this is a
giant waste of time it's a giant waste
of time and has been for 40 years
because number one nobody actually wants
the answers to their questions instead
we just go through this rigmarole to
pretend that these judges don't already
know what they're going to decide on
certain cases and then we ask them and
then they lie and then they go on the
court and they do exactly what we all
thought they were gonna do before unless
they're a Republican appointee in which
it half the cases they do exactly the
opposite of what we thought they were
going to do before in any case Bret
Kevin
is a textualist he's somebody who takes
the text of the Constitution seriously
and that means that the Democrats oppose
him how do we know they oppose him well
because they've said so senator Cory
Booker has already come out and opposed
to him senator Kamala Harris from
California she's already come forward
and opposed him but that's not going to
stop the Democrats from pretending that
the real reason they don't want to give
Brett Kavanaugh a vote is because they
just don't have enough information on
Brett Kavanaugh so they say we need
millions of pages of everything that
Brett Cavanaugh has ever written in
order for us to determine whether he
should sit on the Supreme Court of the
United States again this is a stupid
line considering they have already come
out preemptively and said that they
don't support Brett Kavanaugh for the
Supreme Court of the United States well
once you've said that what's the point
of these hearings now they're doubly
useless number one even if we were gonna
pretend that they were useful you're not
really seeking answers from these
prospective justices and number two when
you've already said you're voting
against the guy are we supposed to take
your prata stations seriously that if
you don't get the materials you're not
going to vote in favor of Brett
Kavanaugh so naturally the whole thing
devolved into farce remember the only
reason Republicans can ram through the
Justice they want right now is because
Harry Reid the former Senate Majority
Leader when he was in power from 2008
till 2010 Harry Reid rammed through
actually it was all the way until 2014
Harry Reid rammed through a process by
which you could through the workings of
51 votes in the Senate get your judicial
nominee he invoked the in 2013 he
invoked the so-called nuclear option
which allowed a ruling from the Senate
Senate Rules Committee that or the
Senate parliamentarian that allowed 51
votes to elevate someone to the Supreme
Court or to any federal court and now
Republicans have just reversed that
process and now they're doing the same
thing that Harry Reid sought to do this
of course has the Democrats fighting mad
and legitimately screaming when I say
legitimately screaming I mean like they
are actually screaming so this is what
it sounded like inside the Senate
Judiciary Committee when Orrin Hatch
opened the actual process and things
went wildly off the rails I welcome
everyone to this confirmation hearing on
the nomination of mr. Brett Kavanaugh
mr. chairman to serve as associate
justice mr. chairman before we
see mr. chairman I'd like to be
recognized to ask a question before we
proceed the committee received just last
night less than 15 hours ago four
thousand pages of documents that we have
not had an opportunity to review we
cannot be recognized I move to adjourn
the American people Chairman I move to
adjourn directly okay so this is all a
bunch of nonsense chuck Grassley is the
Republican senator who's in charge of
that that was Kamala Harris that you
heard there who was saying that she
received all these documents except that
as I mentioned she has already come out
against the nomination of Brett
Kavanaugh so what are the documents
gonna do change her vote in favor of
Brett Kavanaugh of course this is a
bunch of nonsense and then you have Ron
Wyden who's jumping in there and you
have Senator Richard Blumenthal who's
jumping in there a bunch of different
Democratic senators saying well we move
to adjourn guess what buddy you don't
have the votes so this is a waste of
time
what Grassley should have done is you
should have said listen since you're
making a mockery of this we're just
gonna skip the hearing and vote him out
of committee we can save everybody a
month
we'll save everybody a month of time and
stupid effort and instead we'll just
vote the guy directly out of committee
and down to the floor and then we can
have a vote and this guy can be sitting
on the Supreme Court by the end of the
week because that's where this is going
instead we're gonna waste a month with
all of this bureaucratic nonsense or
Democrats opposed because they have to
oppose and Republicans vote for him and
that's the end of the story but I do
enjoy
I do enjoy the theatrics they kind of
Kabuki theater of all this the real
reason that all of these Democrats who
are running for president want the
hearings is they can have their there
there's sort of Ronald Reagan 1980
moment in the 1980 primaries there's a
thing as the New Hampshire primary
debate there's a point where Ronald
Reagan was debating George HW Bush and
he had paid for part of the sponsorship
of the debate and they tried to cut off
his mic and he said I paid for this
microphone mr. Brean and the crowd
erupted it was this big moment all these
Democrats are looking for that except in
the Senate Judiciary Committee they're
all looking for that moment where they
get to say to Brett Kavanaugh you sir
are representative of the regime from
The Handmaid's tell you okay so people
were actually being dragged out I am not
kidding kicking and screaming from the
hearing room a bunch of the folks on the
left
to dress up in hats and handmade
stell costumes they were actually
brought out by their hands and feet like
carried out by their hands and feet
because they were screaming about judge
Brett Kavanaugh wait until President
Trump gets to replace Ruth Bader
Ginsburg on the Supreme Court if you
want to see people burn stuff down
because they're almost doing it for
Brett Kavanaugh who it should be
remembered is replacing Antonin Scalia
another conservative on the court it is
a replacement of a of a originalist by a
originalist she's probably a little bit
softer than Antonin Scalia and yet we're
getting all of this hootenanny
this hot and bothered from from the left
it's really insane I know that they
think under Article 47 of the
Constitution of the United States
there's a wining clause that allows them
to wind their way into obstructing this
but there's no way for them to actually
obstruct this so it's all a waste of
time it's all virtue signaling nonsense
and again all of these judicial hearings
annoy me in the first place because if
somebody were to give an honest answer
they would immediately be ruled out of
order by the Senate we know this because
when Robert Bork gave honest answers
back in the 1980s he was not put on the
Supreme Court for answering honestly
questions about for example Roe vs. Wade
and this led Democrats to quote-unquote
Bork him it became a term of art and now
Democrats do this with anybody who tells
the actual answers to the questions
which we all know okay as a lawyer as a
constitutional lawyer who spent time
talking constitutional law with a wide
variety of experts on the subject and so
I'm not gonna drop my grades I'm not
gonna drop my grades from Harvard Law
like a-plus in constitutional law let's
just say that constitutional law is a
thing I am into okay as somebody who has
studied it for a very long time to
pretend the judges who sit before these
committees don't have extraordinarily
set views on the nature of precedent and
on the nature of particular cases is
just silly but we all sit there and we
pretend anyway because supposedly this
makes our country better in some way it
doesn't they should just vote him out of
committee there's just vote amount to
the Supreme Court we should all
recognize this for what it is a partisan
exercise and it would be a partisan
exercise if the Democrats were to do it
also the Supreme Court has become a
partisan tool because the left made it a
partisan tool decades ago and now the
right is responding by simply trying to
appoint originalist to the bench over
the hoots and howls of insane Democrats
and meanwhile the culture war continues
to polarize the big story over the
weekend is that Nike in a viral piece of
marketing decided that it was deep
necessary to reward colin kaepernick so
you remember colin kaepernick he's at a
relevant backup quarterback from 2016
who made a name for himself by kneeling
for the national anthem and let us
recall that Colin Kaepernick had already
been made a backup quarterback so I
think it was Blaine Gabbert in in San
Francisco in other words he was a
garbage quarterback he's one of the
lowest rated quarterbacks in the NFL I
think he was at the time he was benched
the lowest rated quarterback in the NFL
I got a 32 starting quarterbacks he's
number 32 and Colin Kaepernick was
benched and then in the preseason of
2016 before Trump was president he
started to kneel for the national anthem
it is also to be remembered that Colin
Kaepernick who said he was kneeling for
the national anthem to protest
widespread police brutality or some such
nonsense
he's the kind of person who was wearing
on practice field socks with pictures of
cops as pigs
there's legitimately pictures of pigs
with cop hats on them because this is
what he thinks of police officers this
guy who grew up actually pretty
privileged he was adopted and he grew up
in a pretty privileged area of
California it's it's all kind of
ridiculous it's all kind of ridiculous
but Colin Kaepernick was made into a
national hero by the left which thinks
that it is a Muhammad Ali like stance to
kneel for the national anthem
hey did this in 2016 become a national
issue president Trump commented on it as
a candidate it was very polarizing most
Americans opposed at kneeling for the
anthem but there's a heavy segment
particularly in the black community that
supported Colin Kaepernick kneeling for
the national anthem there's a very big
racial gap and the polling numbers are
kneeling for the national anthem so
Colin Kaepernick was offered in 2017 a
or in 2016 he was offered the chance to
join the Denver Broncos John Elway
announced this in 2018 he was asked
about picking up Colin Kaepernick and he
said I said this a while ago Colin had
his chance to be here we offered him a
contract and he didn't take it oh it was
referring to the 2016 season Denver
tried to trade for Kaepernick who's
under contract at the 49ers at a time
the quarterback would not agree to a
restructured deal with Denver and then
the Broncos selected a couple of backup
quarterbacks and he lost his opportunity
and it turned out nobody really wanted
the headache of Colin Kaepernick not
just because of the publicity
although publicity is something you have
to take into account when you are a
national football league team but also
because he's just not a very good
quarterback because Colin Kaepernick
after basically once
Killer season fell off the map and
that's not unusual they're a bunch of
quarterbacks in the NFL who've had one
great season then fallen off the map and
this has nothing to do with politics
I remember rg3 who's a quarterback in in
in Washington for the Redskins had one
fantastic season and then he sort of
fell off the map and that's not unusual
again once people figure out your sort
of tricks as a quarterback it's
difficult to recover and that's sort of
what happened to Kaepernick overall but
Kaepernick played his way out of a
starting job and then once he was on the
bench he started kneeling for the
national anthem it is now two years
later and this conversation has not
ceased since it has continued to be a
thorn in the side of the NFL ever since
because the NFL didn't take strict
action against it and we'll talk about
the latest iteration of this controversy
in just one second but first let's talk
about the food that you are shoveling
into your face so blue apron is gonna
get you better food ok blue apron is
gonna get you tastier food and more
importantly blue apron is going to bring
all the ingredients to you with the
recipe and you can cook it at home with
your kids you can maybe be making
gourmet dinner in as little as twenty
minutes with quick and easy recipe
options with insanely delicious flavors
perfectly portioned ingredients
delivered directly to your door you skip
the meal planning and shopping you get
straight to cooking with blue apron it
really is an amazing meal delivery
service and they offer a range of
recipes bursting with flavor
whether you're looking for those quick
and easy meals where a full kuelen Airy
cooking experience blue apron lets you
choose from a range of recipe options
chef's designed recipes exciting
September partnerships Bob burgers
inspired and whole thirty approved so
check out this week's menu your first
three meals for free at blue apron comm
slash Shapiro that's blue apron comm
slash up hero and get your first three
meals for free I'm looking at some of
these meals and again you're gonna be
cooking like you're a four-star chef
look it was pasta and creamy tomato
sauce crispy chicken tenders and mashed
potatoes all this stuff looks gourmet
you're cooking at yourself with your
family it's just great blue apron is
indeed a better way to cook go check it
out get three meals for free your first
three meals free at blue apron comm
slash Shapiro so go check that up right
now so the latest iteration of the Colin
Kaepernick controversy because it has
continued all the way till now President
Trump I said I didn't think you should
get involved in this he did as president
because he likes this culture war he
thinks it's a good culture war to fight
he thinks he wins this culture war and
he's likely right he does win this
culture war but at the cost of
polarizing the debate a little bit more
when President Trump took office some 75
sense of Americans thought kneeling for
the national anthem was bad now that
number is in the low 60s last time I
checked a lot of that has to do with
president Trump's polarizing personality
with all of that said the media have
latched on to the national anthem
controversy and they have not let go
since the NFL has done a horrible job of
killing the controversy instead of just
killing it at the outset by saying
listen you don't get to kneel for the
anthem you're fine you want to protest
on in your office in your off hours
enjoy but you don't get to do it on our
fields instead of them doing that they
allowed it to happen they'd allow her to
fester and it ended up hurting the NFL
in a pretty serious way the ratings for
the NFL have been in decline for the
last two years it's been a serious image
issue for the NFL well now Nike is
jumping into the fray so Nike decided
that they are going to do the this this
huge ad campaign that is going to focus
on Colin Kaepernick he is part of the
30th anniversary of Nikes just do it
campaign and here is what the ad looks
like it's a picture of Colin Kaepernick
a close-up of his face in black and
white and says believe in something even
if it means sacrificing everything and
then there's the Nike swoosh it says
just do it okay so there's so many
elements of this that are just
fabulously ironic first of all this
social justice warrior campaign to sell
sneakers produced by small children in
Vietnam presumably it's kind of
hilarious watching the entire left
resonates around a huge billion dollar
company a huge corporation that
allegedly exploits child labor in
third-world countries because hey Colin
Kapernick that's pretty hilarious it is
also kind of hilarious that the slogan
itself believe in something even if it
means sacrificing everything it's a
really dumb slogan in fact it's
basically Thanos his slogan from
Avengers infinity wars believe in
something even if it means sacrificing
half of humanity what you believe is
actually the key issue I mean if we're
actually gonna take that slogan
seriously believe in something even if
it means sacrificing everything it's not
about believing in something it's about
what you believe in the question is are
you believing the right things Colin
Kaepernick is not he's never provided a
shred of data to support his assertions
that black people in the United States
are being disproportionately shot by
police because in fact they are not and
then we get to the actual issue of Colin
Kaepernick being the face of this
particular culture war we get to the the
bottom line here and
there's a great irony to it which I'll
discuss in just a second so colin
kaepernick again says believe in
something even if it means sacrificing
everything over his face for the Nike
just do it campaign I do love the fact
that when you hashtag just do it with
all the capitals properly utilized it
looks like just don't but in any case
using colin kaepernick he's a poor
example of this because he didn't
sacrifice anything colin kaepernick did
not sacrifice a thing if we're gonna
talk about people who sacrificed in the
NFL there are legitimate former military
members in the NFL a pat tillman
died in the line of duty work' you know
as a soldier in in afghanistan for the
NFL did nike do a campaign around him of
course they didn't read they they just
do it around around colin kaepernick
and this is for capitalistic reasons it
is to make money Nike is a corporation
they know we'll be talking about it
today they hope that by right-wingers
talking about it they will drive more
people on the left to go out and buy
sneakers on the basis of we don't like
President Trump and let's be frank about
this this is an anti Trump campaign this
rally first started in the 2016 campaign
if Hillary Clinton were president right
now do you think that Nike would
actually be running this ad campaign of
course not of course not
Colin Kaepernick is not sacrificed to
anything not only did he not sacrifice
nothing he only started doing this when
he became a useless backup quarterback
for the San Francisco 49ers and then
after that he has kept his name in the
headlines he's been on the cover of
Sports Illustrated despite not playing
for two years yeah Tim Tebow isn't on
the cover of Sports Illustrated every
two weeks because Tim Tebow isn't in
with the social justice warrior crowd
but Tim Tebow was in many ways sort of
the equivalent of Colin Kaepernick and
that he had one kind of terrific season
where he unexpectedly led the Denver
Broncos to wins in the playoffs and then
he fell off the map but Colin Kaepernick
you know he took over for Alex Smith
halfway through a season with the San
Francisco 49ers they went to the Super
Bowl he lost and then he was nothing
okay and but but still he's on the cover
of Sports Illustrated he's still
champion as this this thought leader
even though I'm not sure Colin
Kaepernick has ever had any real thought
and the reason I say that is because
Colin Kaepernick has never made an
articulate defense of his own position
on any of this stuff there are people
who have made articulate defenses on his
behalf but he's never done it himself he
has not sacrificed anything and he's
slated to earn legitimately millions of
dollars he's gonna get a break
the line off of not being in athletics
for two years he's getting a brand in
the line and he is going to get and he's
gonna make millions of dollars off of
kneeling for the national anthem so why
is Nike doing all of this precisely so
that we'll talk about it it is a troll
it's obviously a troll they are hoping
that the President of the United States
sounds off about it Trump undoubtedly
will sign off on it I mean he will
undoubtedly sound off about it on
Twitter because he thinks again that
this is a culture war worth fighting but
there's no question that this is all
designed to sell more sneakers and one
of the reasons that Nike thinks that
they can get away with this obviously is
because disproportionate amounts of
money are spent on clothing and apparel
by members of the black community many
of whom are supporters of Colin
Kaepernick in this particular
controversy that is not a racial
supposition that is that economics
opposition economist Kerwin Charles Eric
Hearst Nikolai rusinov from University
of Chicago did a study called
conspicuous consumption and race and
what they found is that blacks and
Hispanics spent a lot more than whites
with come with comparable in comes on
visible goods meaning clothes cars and
jewelry up to an additional 30% there's
been a long-standing long-standing sort
of sociological investigation into why
for example it seems that lower-income
black folks spend more on sneakers and
some of that has to do with with pride
and culture some of that has to do with
the fact that you know like Air Jordans
were a massive cultural totem in the
1990s oh that is true but just for
capitalistic purposes it's pretty
obvious that Nike is attempting to
appeal to this particular consumer base
along with a left that will resonate to
the support of Colin Kaepernick and it's
also important to note that according to
Nielsen african-americans are more
likely to interact with brands on social
media or to use social networks to
support companies and brands 44% more
likely so they're hoping that this
campaign goes viral particularly among
black audiences and that people on the
Left will resonate to this as well so in
the end capitalism wins the great irony
of this is that the social justice
warriors championing this they're really
championing the power of capitalism but
is it insulting of course it's insulting
is designed to slap President Trump of
course it's designed to slap President
Trump and honestly I'm not sure the
President Trump could ask for much more
Nike made an in-kind contribution to the
Trump campaign because of this battle in
2018 and 2020 is going to be about
kneeling for the flag most Americans are
not on board with that most Americans
don't
colin kaepernick can see an American
Hero they don't even see a guy who's
made a lot of sacrifices Muhammad Ali
was the champion of the world he's the
heavyweight boxing champion of the world
when he was suspended from boxing for
not volunteering for the Vietnam draft
or not being drafted and for saying
things about the Vietcong and all this
kind of stuff under the influence of
Elijah Muhammad in the evil Nation of
Islam but at least he sacrifice
something or the guys sacrificed years
of his career he went to jail for this
colin kaepernick and sacrifice zero
things but apparently he's sacrificing
everything means signing contracts worth
millions of dollars in order to promote
promote a quote unquote globalist brand
that is selling sneakers made it half
price off by child labor so that's
that's exciting stuff
speaking of sort of virtue signaling and
in the backlash to President Trump the
other big story over the weekend was
obviously the the funeral for John
McCain we're going to talk about that in
just one second but first let's talk
about your clothing so do you see this
jacket that I'm wearing right now look
at this magnificent piece of clothing
this right here is a Peter Millar jacket
and it is spectacular I own several
Peter Millar polo shirts because they're
extraordinarily comfortable and they are
easy wear they look really good okay
this is the excursion display sir by the
way that's the name of this section of
names that's how upscale this clothing
is Peter Millar polo shirt offer style
and comfort they are easy to take care
of out of the dryer you don't have to
put an iron to them they are great for
the golf course because they even have
sun protection built into the shirt
Peter Millar five pocket pants they're
lightweight highly breathable made from
the highest quality pima cotton and have
comfort stretch for ease of movement by
the way I love their shorts how about
Peter Moeller shirts around I know to
the to the great horror of people who
don't want to see my knees that's just
the way that that works guys peter mow
our performance shorts their moisture
wicking breathable quick-drying they've
a stretch waistband so they move with
you which makes them great for playing
around a golf or just walking around
with your kids I never have to worry
about what I'm going to wear for any
occasion because Peter Millar has me
covered
they're my go-to clothing for vacation
were commenced the golf course even
working out I put on Peter Millar in the
morning I wear it all day and it is just
great go check them out right now at
Peter Moeller comm slash men to check
out some of my Peter Millar favorites be
sure to use my link you'll receive
complimentary shipping and a free hat
that's Peter Millar mi loa our comm
slash Ben again Peter Maillard comm
slash Ben go check it out right now
Peter Miller comm slash Ben and when you
do that you receive complimentary
shipping and a free hat as well
okay so John McCain's funeral took place
over the weekend is after a week
of American morning for a for an
American patriot and hero but his
funeral turned into a bit of a as I've
said in the past a turd tornado it
turned into a bit of craziness and
that's because a bunch of speakers
decided to get up in bash president Ron
now do I think the president Trump
treated John McCain well in life no I
don't I think it was ridiculous for a
president Trump to say the trauma came
was not a war heroes kind of a gross
thing to say do I think that John McCain
didn't like president Trump yes it seems
to me that his peak and his anger at
President Trump led him to make a
terrible decision when it came to
Obamacare and prevent the the
overthrowing of large portions of
Obamacare simply out of a level of
personal pique was a huge John McCain
fan as a politician no I was not a huge
John McCain fan as a politician but with
that said was a petty for the President
to not lower the the flag to half-staff
for a week as a sort of normal procedure
yes it was petty didn't look silly yes
it looked silly the president should
have been should not have engaged that
way with that said using a funeral in
order to promote an anti-trump agenda is
foolish for a couple of reasons first of
all I think that John McCain's life was
about a fair bit more than Donald Trump
I really do I mean there's a guy who had
served since the late 1960s boiling that
down to an anti Trump message seems to
me a real you know non proper evaluation
of his role in American history and what
he was and listen
his Megan McCain essay what she wants is
about about her father it's her father
she gets to say whatever she wants but
we also get to criticize that once we
stray into overtly political territory
and there a lot of commentators saying
well there are no overt slaps of Trump
let's not be intellectually dishonest it
was very obvious that there are a bunch
of overt slaps at President Trump and
more than that I think it was
counterproductive even if you don't like
the way that President Trump goes about
politics even if you think that
President Trump is uncivil which I do
even if you think the President Trump
does not serve his own purpose as well
when he lashes out at people which I do
even if you think the President Trump
says things that are cruel and vile on a
fairly frequent basis which I do is it
worthwhile is it useful for a bunch of
people to get up at John McCain's
funeral and say all of this stuff and
more importantly is he useful to do that
from quote-unquote both sides of the
aisle because I think that what that's
doing is promulgating a myth that Trump
is actually the response to
the myth is that there was a civil
politics before Trump there was not had
the idea that there was a civil politics
before Trump means that you were not
watching for twenty thirty forty years
you were not watching in the 1960s there
were political riots in this country at
the 1968 Chicago convention there were
legitimate riots in the street at the
Democratic National Convention there
were thousands of bombings political
bombings across the United States in the
1970s during the during the Barack Obama
administrations we saw administration we
saw riots in Baltimore we saw riots in
Ferguson
we saw riots in other places in the
United States and we saw at president
Trump's rallies during the 2016 campaign
Trump supporters being physically beaten
we saw President Trump have to cancel an
actual rally in Chicago due to
intimidation outside the events we've
seen over the past several years before
Trump was in office when I went to
Berkeley I required six hundred police
officers to protect me I remember there
was there's a near riot when I spoke at
Cal State Los Angeles and I was before
Trump was president the idea that
politics was some sort of civil game
where everybody got along before
President Trump is nonsense and more
than that to paper over the serious
political divisions in this country with
this veneer of civility it makes it look
like there's a professional political
class invested in civility because they
actually like each other and Trump is
the great outsider and so we don't like
Trump because he's the great outsider
again there are legitimate reasons to
criticize the President of the United
States for his approach to politics but
when you promulgate this absolute myth
this absolute myth that there was a
civil politics between say Barack Obama
and John McCain or Barack Obama and
George HW Bush when Barack Obama
basically called George W Bush a war
criminal I mean back in 2000 I think
this is 2003 this is Barack Obama
talking about the situation Afghanistan
this is audio uncovered in 2007 this is
this is Barack Obama I guess it was in
talking about george w bush's troops you
know his the service of troops under
george w bush in afghanistan you've got
to get the job done there and that
requires us to have enough troops that
we're not just air raiding villages and
killing civilians which is causing
enormous problems there
okay Barack Obama accusing george w bush
of presiding effectively over war crimes
but we are supposed to believe that it
was donald trump who broke our politics
this is why i say all of us least
a backlash in favor of President Trump
having all of these these mainstream
political figures from both sides of the
aisle kind of unite in opposition to
Trump but not on the basis of actual
sins committed by President Trump on the
basis of he's just not nice enough and
look how we get along look how George W
Bush and Bill Clinton get along look how
George W Bush and Barack Obama get along
I don't like that part of politics okay
but there's this there's this sense in
in I'm a sports fan so as a sports fan
there used to be something called non
frat of fraternization rules in sports
where it was like the New York Yankees
were playing the Boston Red Sox and you
weren't allowed to go out to dinner with
members of the opposing team after the
game because you felt that that sort of
sacrificed the competitive edge that if
you were to close with your competitors
then the sacrifice the competitive edge
and so there are all these owners who
basically said you're not allowed to
fraternize with members of the
opposition team and as a fan that makes
sense to me because I don't want to see
my favorite player who has to face down
that batter tomorrow I don't want to
know that they're best friends it
doesn't it doesn't help because I want
to root for my team to root against the
other team all in politics that rooting
actually has real stakes I don't want
George W Bush to be best friends with
Barack Obama
I don't want George W Bush to be best
friends with Bill Clinton I want them to
be civil I want them to recognize that
they shouldn't be demagoguing issues
that's where you can criticize President
Trump but when you act like your best
friends and your buddy buddy and we're
all part of this big group loves each
other and then there's that yeah that
Trump guy all that ends up doing is
driving people into presidential I mean
ironically it helps president Trump
because even people like me look at this
and they go I'm sorry but if politics is
how nice George W Bush is to Michelle
Obama by handing her candy I'm not all
that interested because the the things
they do have real stakes the the
politics that they embrace have actual
stakes and again you're saying I'm
somebody who is warm toward the argument
that President Trump has not been good
for American politics in a wide variety
of ways but when you push this this lie
that politics is really about George W
Bush and Michelle Obama being besties
and there are no consequences to any of
this I don't care whether George Dobie
Bush likes Michelle Obama I don't care
whether whether George HW and Bill
Clinton are friends I don't want them to
be friends because I don't think that
that is reflective of deep underlying
political differences that exist in this
country
I want them to be battling tooth and
nail if they can be friends in battle
too
that's one thing but I don't think that
they were battling tooth and nail I
think that there there's a feeling in
this country that the elites in both
parties are actually back patting each
other and are too friendly for the good
of the country then what we actually
need in some ways is more political
conflict that doesn't mean more
incivility but again like people were
champion okay look how nice it was the
george w bush is handing michelle obama
candy listen is it fine that he's
handing her candy sure like i'm not
gonna pretend that i think he should
reject the candy and i don't mean that
you shouldn't hand michelle obama candy
but by the same token people celebrating
this is oh well isn't this what american
politics is really about george w bush
honey michelle obama candy no it seems
to me what american politics is really
about is barack obama slandering george
w bush is a war criminal for eight years
and then running on the back of that to
become presidents of the united states
and proud and push policies actively
create policies that are targeted at
people like me right that like and i
want to see people i mean particularly
religious conservatives that's the part
I care about I care about them handing
candy to each other people feel there's
a veneer to politics that is a lie and
this this all was part of the veneer of
politics that was a lie in a second I'm
going to show you the clips of these
various speakers who are engaging I'm
going to show you why people think this
is a lie but first let's talk about your
life insurance so if you do not have
life insurance it's because you're a
dolt you need a life insurance okay the
reality is you're going to die at some
point when you do you want to make sure
that your family is taken care of and
that is why you need to talk to my
friends over at policy genius forty
percent of Americans don't have it the
younger you are the less likely you are
to have life insurance that's stupid
because rates are much better when you
are younger and also rates are the best
they've been in twenty years it's the
easy way to get life insurance online in
two minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you when you compare quotes you save
money it is indeed that simple policy
genius has helped over 4 million people
shop for insurance they've placed over
twenty billion dollars in coverage they
don't just make life insurance easy
they also compare disability insurance
and renter's insurance and health
insurance if you care about it they can
cover it so if you're looking for a good
reason to buy life insurance I've got
three it's national life insurance
Awareness Month number one number two
rates aren't a 20-year low and number
three policy genius makes it easy for
you so go check it out right now
policy genius.com get quotes applying
minutes you know the whole thing on your
phone right now
policy genius is indeed the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance again
policy genius.com let them know that we
sent you
all righty so in just one second I want
to get into the actual material from the
funeral but first you're gonna have to
go over to Daily wire comm and subscribe
for $9.99 a month you can get a
subscription to daily wire comm when you
do you get the rest of the show live
dressed mandrel clave ins show live
there are so Michael Knowles is show
live and you also get to be part of the
mailbag on Fridays where you ask me all
your questions and I give you answers
for the low annual subscription of $99
ear you get this the very greatest in
all beverage vessels leftist ears hot or
cold tumbler behold its glory see the
wisdom that emanates therefrom go check
it out right now and it's cheaper than
the monthly subscription also subscribe
to us over at youtube or itunes and when
you do you get our Sunday special we
have a big Sunday special coming up this
Sunday and we will announce that guest a
little bit later this week go check us
out we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
so here are the clips of the various
people at McCain's funeral bashing
President Trump you're going to see
George W Bush Barack Obama and Meghan
McCain go after President Trump again
everybody has the freely right to say
what they want about president Trump but
do I think that this is productive in
terms of forwarding the national
discourse I don't I actually don't
I think this is counterproductive I
think that it leads people to believe
that there is this sort of near
conspiracy of silence on the part of the
elites in our country who fraternize
behind the scenes and then expect us to
take seriously their conflicts on the
actual field of play so here are some of
these clips the America of John McCain
is generous and welcoming and bold she
is resourceful and confidently secured
she meets her responsibilities she
speaks quietly because she is strong
America does not both because she has no
need to the America of John McCain has
no need to be made great again because
America was always great okay so that
that that's sort of yeah sloganeering
about the America of John McCain was
always great obviously it's a direct
slap at President Trump again I know
Megan McCain I think the megan mccain
says a lot of smart and good things I
think that this was a thing he was a
politically inept move I think there's a
politically inept move and she does say
what you want her dad's the one who's in
the coffin but still so I have to
analyze this politically do I think it
was effective or not in making the
country a better place
bring her bring the country around to
John McCain's brand of politics I don't
think so here's George W Bush doing some
of this in he respected the dignity
inherent in every life a dignity that
does not stop at borders and cannot be
erased by dictators perhaps above all
john de tested the abuse of power
okay so again people took this as an
implicit rebuke of President Trump and
then Barack Obama gets up and Barack
Obama of course is somebody who abused
power quite frequently right you have
george w bush critiquing abuse of power
there's Barack Obama a man who basically
weaponized his IRS against his political
opposition doing the same routine part
of what makes our country great
is that our membership is based not on
our bloodline not on what we look like
what our last name SAR it's not based on
where our parents or grandparents came
from or how recently they arrived but on
adherence to a common creed that all of
us are created equal again this idea
that that Barack Obama and George W Bush
are on the same political side and
Donald Trump is on the other political
side I think it's a big mistake because
the reality is that Barack Obama was
pushing things Barack Obama was was
pushing a race-based politics
particularly in 2012 and Beyond in which
he was saying things like Trayvon Martin
could have been my son suggesting police
departments across the country were
racist here is why people aren't taking
this seriously here's why people look at
this and they get a little on the right
and they feel uncomfortable and Agana
this is coming from somebody who blasted
president Trump last week over his
mistreatment of John McCain I mean I
blasted him last week if you recall back
that far I still think this was not only
inappropriate I think it was politically
dishonest because when you move over to
how the left side of the aisle treats
people the left side does not treat
people with civility the left side
treated John McCain like trash while he
was alive until he turned toward their
side at which point he became a hero
that's having left always treats people
how do I know this because well they're
calling for civility civility and while
people like George W Bush are are
calling for civility and saying we ought
to treat with the other side and not
just calling for civility but calling
for compromise and moderation here's
what is actually happening in sort of
leftist halls all we have to do is is
skip over to the Aretha Franklin funeral
which also happened over the weekend
where Al Sharpton an actual open
anti-semite was speaking and ripping
into President Trump with Bill Clinton
sitting right there in the audience you
know two of the Sunday on my show I've
misspelled respect and a lot of y'all
lot of y'all corrected me now I want
y'all to help me correct President Trump
to teach him what it means
okay and there's everybody cheering and
President Clinton is sitting right there
here's a picture of President Clinton on
stage with three a great racists here's
President Clinton standing next to Jesse
Jackson who called New York Jaime town
al Sharpton who talked about diamond
merchants in Crown Heights and led to
the and his language helped incite a
riot and Louis Farrakhan who is called
the Jews Devils and white people devils
and there's Bill Clinton standing there
grinning alongside them so you're
telling me that our politics is about
Bill Clinton being friends with George
HW Bush but in his off hours Bill
Clinton gets to hang out with people who
are essentially the equivalent of David
Duke Lewis Farrakhan is the equivalent
of David Duke and there's Bill Clinton
standing on stage with him hanging out
with them they're best friends
everything's great and then then we're
gonna get lectures about civility this
is how you got Trump because there's a
hypocritical sense that all of these
elites are happy to back slap each other
and go to the same clubs and smoke
cigars with one another and then they
pretend for the cameras they play this
Kabuki theater again everything's about
Kabuki theater they're out there playing
this game where they pretend to dislike
each other and oppose each other on
politics now I think you can oppose each
other on politics and still be civil to
one another I think that you can rip the
President of the United States when he's
being not only uncivil but vile in
particular cases I've done it myself
many times do I think that using a
funeral as the opportunity to show
bipartisan support for the for the anti
Trump tactics is that is that a
worthwhile thing now I think it strikes
people it strikes a false note it
strikes a false note for people and
makes people think it's Trump versus the
establishment which again is the battle
Trump actually wants right the battle
Trump wants is Trump versus the
establishment because people don't
actually like the establishment very
much it's that feeling of buddy-buddy
Chum er II there's a different scene
being civil and being best friends
there's a difference between being civil
and pretending that the other guy's
political point of view is in some way
the same as mine and that's what was
happening there right George George W
Bush and Barack Obama were speaking of a
common American vision that they do not
share Barack Obama's vision of the
United States and george w bush's vision
of the united states are not the same
and there are a lot of folks who are
going to perceive that if george w
bush's vision of the United States and
Barack Obama's vision of the United
States are more closely tied together
than Donald Trump's in george w bush's
and yet for some odd reason donald trump
is implementing conservative policies in
the same way Bush would have done then
something
gone wrong and the real gap here is a
cultural gap not really a political gap
at all okay meanwhile I do have to show
you this is from Aretha Franklin's
funeral the same group of people who are
ripping into Donald Trump for being you
know uncivil and awful and terrible and
and garbage you with regard to women
again some of which I think is justified
these are the same people who are
hanging out with with Bill frickin
Clinton you got yet George HW Bush who
plays buddy-buddy with Bill Clinton
here's Bill Clinton at Aretha Franklin's
funeral checking out Aria Gras
Ariana Grande's but Ariana Grande first
of all looks like she's 16 years old and
there's Bill Clinton who looks like the
the old child molester from Family Guy
just sitting behind Ariana Grande and
legitimately can see him stare her up
and down and that's the kind of class
that our politics is supposed to stand
for now Bill Clinton he understands the
American vision but Donald Trump doesn't
understand the American vision what a
bunch of absolute horror crap horse crap
so much of trumps power so much of his
persona is driven by the fact that it
feels like he's ripping away curtains
that there's a veil of of pretend that
he just tears apart and contributing to
this veil of pretend is not useful
America is built on a creed America is
built on the idea that we are brothers
and not enemies all of that is true and
when President Trump does things that
are terrible we ought to comment on it
but to pretend that there are not
serious differences between left and
right in the country that the real
differences are between the civil and
the uncivil is I think ignorant of the
reality of the situation
now speaking of areas where the
president deserves criticism the
president over the weekend decided to
take to Twitter as he is fond of doing
and he tweeted out a bunch of cryptic
and bizarre things so he tweeted out to
long-running
Obama era investigations of two very
popular Republican congressman were
brought to a well-publicized charge just
ahead of the midterms by the Jeff
Sessions Justice Department two easy
wins now in doubt because there is not
enough time good job Jeff the Democrats
none of whom voted for Jeff Sessions
must love him now same thing with lyin
James Comey the terms I hated him wanted
him out until he was disgusting until I
fired him all caps immediately he became
a wonderful man a saint like figure in
fact really thick and so the part of
this that's troubling is not all the
stuff about James Comey
just um the part that that's really
troubling is in the first tweet here
when he says the Jeff Sessions and the
DOJ should not prosecute actual
corruption in government because it
might endanger congressional seats
you're not supposed to say that part out
loud mr. president when you suggest that
the rule of law comes secondary to the
political victory of your own party it's
not a good thing that is a bad thing and
it was a bad thing when Obama was doing
it and it's a bad thing when President
Trump is doing it's a bad thing when the
Attorney General is the president's
wingman and ignoring crime and the
president's is using executive privilege
to shield particular figures which is
what Barack Obama didn't it's a bad
thing when the President of the United
States is bizarrely going on Twitter to
rip the Attorney General who works for
him for prosecuting actual crime in
Congress so there was that and then the
president also decided to tweet out
about the FBI and according to the
failing New York Times the FBI started a
major effort to flip Putin loyalists in
2014 to 2016
it wasn't about Trump he wasn't even
close to a candidate yet rigged
witch-hunt
I'm so confused by this tweet I can't
even express is he ripping the FBI for
trying to go after Putin loyalists
before he was even running for office is
that the point he's making here I mean
to be charitable I guess maybe the point
that he's making is maybe that this
investigation preceded anything having
to do with Donald Trump and that he's
been kind of swept up in an
investigation has nothing to do with him
but he's not making that particularly
clear there are plenty of grounds on
which to criticize the President of the
United States claiming that the left and
the right are on the same page and Trump
is not and the Trump is something
foreign to politics when we all know
that Trump was the seething underbelly
of politics for at least two decades in
this country is just historically
ignorant and also incredibly stupid
again also that the tolerant left is so
tolerant that they are now disinviting
peoples in The New Yorker I love this
invited Steve Bannon to do an event
Steve Danon as the former White House
chief strategist I am a longtime critic
of Steve Bannon who I think is a flaming
garbage heap of a human being The New
Yorker shouldn't have invited him he's
been irrelevant to politics since
President Trump fired him and labeled
him sloppy Steve but they invited him
and then a bunch of left he's dropped
out and then they decided okay well
we'll just invite him you shouldn't
invite people and just invite them if
you don't want to invite Steve Bannon
don't invite him if he does invite him
because of pressure from your mailroom
then I would suggest that you guys lack
a little bit of courage in regard to
your your devotion to open conversation
obviously okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things I like today last night I had the
opportunity to go see operation finale
with Oscar Isaac and and Ben Kingsley
Ben Kingsley is one of the best living
actors Ben Kingsley is just tremendous
in everything and he is predictably
excellent in this he plays Adolph
Eichmann the Nazi had a mastermind of
logistics during the Holocaust and Oscar
Isaac plays an Israeli agent who is
tasked with tracking him down not only
tracking him down but also getting him
to sign the documents that gives
permission for his trial to be held in
Israel and the face-off between the two
of them is the best part of the movie
the movie is effective it's very
effective not only is it effective I was
I'm always pleased when there's no
sucker punches so whenever I see a movie
that set up like this I always think
okay here comes the sucker punch here
comes the Steven Spielberg Munich like
sucker punch where we learned that the
Israelis are really the Nazis or the
Israelis are really the great oppressors
in Munich that's what Spielberg did he
had terra palestinian terrorists
murdered Israeli athletes at the
Olympics and somehow Steven Spielberg
drew a moral equivalence between those
people and Israeli agents tracking them
down which is an amazing amazing feat of
sort of intellectual gymnastics in moral
gymnastics in this particular movie
however there are no sucker punches
Israel is perceived as good because it
is a good country filled with people who
are trying to survive in the face of
radical anti-semitism across the world
and the Nazis are bad also the movie
takes on some serious issues with regard
to the banality of evil
so Hannah Arendt a very very famous
writer with I would have say far left
leanings on politics she wrote an entire
book called Eichmann in Jerusalem about
Eichmann's trial because I even was in
fact brought back to Israel for trial he
was put inside a glass booth actually to
prevent him from being assassinated and
he and he was then hang hana rents did
an entire book on him and basically she
made the claim that Eichmann was just an
effect of the banality of evil to phrase
use the banality of evil now I have some
fondness toward the idea that human
beings our program to look the other way
when they're in group is threatened when
you're in group is threatened that you
tend to go along with evil but for you
to be an architect
and evil I think requires a little bit
more it seems that later research has
sort of shown hunter wrens banality of
evil point as applied to Adolf Eichmann
to be kind of ridiculous that Edelman
was in fact a rabid anti-semite who
hated Jews and was willing to use any
method at his disposal to kill them in
large numbers but the movie really does
cope with with some of those issues here
is a little bit of the preview for
operation finale you have no interest in
what I have to say unless it confirms
what you think you already know my job
was simple save the country I loved from
being destroyed your job any different
so the movie is quite good again it's
it's I think it doesn't sucker punch
anybody it does demonstrate the one one
thing that is shocking is the virulence
of anti-semitism under the Peron regime
in in Argentina they you have a you have
a bunch of people on the Left who
somehow still have fondness for the
Parana stand in Argentina which is kind
of shocking but the the Peron regime was
indeed an evil regime and they shielded
a crapload of Nazis who are attempting
to escape justice after World War two go
check it out operation finales in
theaters right now it is well worth the
watch it's it's definitely disturbing
but it should be disturbing it's a movie
about the Holocaust in the aftermath of
the Holocaust so go check it out right
now operation finale okay other things
that I like so speaking of American flag
controversies last week we talked at
length about this new movie first man
from Damien Chazelle honestly I'm very
sad that Damien Chazelle is being held
controversy because I think he's one of
the best directors working today
I think lala land for its flaws it's a
very good movie and I think the whiplash
is a terrific movie one of the best
movies the last ten years well his new
movie first man about Neil Armstrong
doesn't contain Americans planting the
flag on the moon we all know why it's
because he's afraid that it's going to
kill the box office in China but Ryan
Gosling went out there and suggested
that it was because it was an
international achievement a world
achievement to put a man on the moon not
an American achievement which of course
is a bunch of nonsense Buzz Aldrin who
was part of the Apollo 11 mission he
also tweeted out a picture of them
putting up the flag on the moon and then
he tweeted out hashtag proud to be an
American
hashtag freedom hashtag honor hashtag
one nation hashtag July 1969 hashtag
Apollo 11 hashtag Road to Apollo 50 like
yes okay yes this is not a difficult one
the fact that the that Americans put the
flag on the moon is an amazing
achievement especially given the fact
they were essentially using slide rules
it's it's it's an amazing thing and it
is an American achievement because
America has been the world power and the
the single dominant hegemony over the
globe for ever since World War two and
probably before World War two although
we really only began to take more of an
active role in world affairs during and
after World War two okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so you've
heard all this stuff about how the
Swedish healthcare system is just the
best health care system how nationalized
health care systems they have no cost
everything is fantastic and nationalized
health care systems
well Sweden is not a hugely populous
country but it is a country where people
are taxed at more than half their income
the total population of Sweden is about
nine point nine million which is about
the size of Los Angeles County but we
are told that if we just applied Swedish
solutions to our health care everything
would be all better there's an article
in Oh Charles France Presse today all
about the Swedish healthcare system and
here is what they find Swedes are
frustrated over their universal health
care one of the main pillars of their
cherished welfare state with long queues
due to a shortage of nurses and
available doctors in some areas no you
mean a man on market-based system
generates shortages I can't believe it
just like in every other product in
human history when you have a non
market-based system then price and
supply do not match I kept no demand and
supply curves actually what what I
thought if you declared something right
then the laws of supply and demand no
longer apply if you're stupid so Swedes
who on average pay more than half of
their income in tax sea access to health
care is the most important issue in the
September 9th general election poll
prime minister stefan la la finns
social democrats largest party are on
course for a record low score there
instead losing to the far-right sweden
democrats who i believe started off with
actual actual neo-nazi roots if i'm not
mistaken so the far-right is gaining
because sweden has not taken immigration
seriously and because all of these
social welfare promises of the swedish
state are experiencing some difficulty
then the 2016 nationwide mean ian wait
for prostate cancer was 120 days but 207
one days in the northern County a
västerbotten official figures show
Swedes complained about not being able
to see their own regular general
practitioner as a growing number of
doctors and nurses are temporary hires
employed by staffing companies some 80
percent of the healthcare sector is in
need of nurses according to official
data which means that's under estimating
online services where patients see a
doctor via webcam have mushroomed as
well so everything is going
spectacularly and what are the so what
are the Social Democrats vowing they are
vowing to spend 3 billion kroner to hire
more healthcare staff if reelected so
they're gonna spend their way out of the
crisis we'll see if that works
eventually the bill comes due for all of
this so it is worth noting this whenever
you hear about the wonders and glories
of nationalized healthcare systems again
this is not an offense of the American
healthcare system which is almost the
worst of both worlds heavily regulated
and then free market with massive
subsidies and then it's the American
healthcare system is a mess but the
solution is not a nationalized health
care system at least not in the way the
Swedes do it okay so meanwhile Pope
Francis on Monday said silence and
prayer were the answer to those seeking
scandal and division amid a barrage of
attacks from ultra conservative
Catholics first of all I love how Yahoo
News in the AFP call it attacks from
ultra conservative Catholics as opposed
to you know Catholics you don't like
seeing little boys molested by priests
now they're ultra conservative so back
in 2003 when it was the spotlight
scandal then it was every good hearted
person learning to stop the abuse of
children now it's ultra conservative
Catholics I can't believe the press is
taking this line but this is how much
they love their leftist Pope Francis the
Pope has so far refused to respond to
allegations made last month that he for
years covered up sexual abuse
allegations against a prominent US
Cardinal Francis senator prayer service
at st. Martha at st. Martha's with
people who lacked goodwill with people
who seek only scandal who seek only
division who seek only destruction even
within the family there is nothing but
silence and prayer or theoretically you
could fire everybody who is abusing a
child turn them over to civil
authorities and have them prosecuted or
theoretically you could reveal all of
your records to the general public so we
know who exactly was covering up what or
I guess you could stay silent pretend
it's not a big deal in little boys get
raped I guess you could do that and
honest to god it's just it's astonishing
it's astonishing to watch the press
cover for Pope Francis
if Benedict had done the same thing if
John Paul to had done the same thing
and this sort of scandal had broken the
press would be ripping them up and down
endlessly ceaselessly with no break it
is Pope Francis was a leftist on a bunch
of issues from economics to the
environment and therefore he will be
defended with the hardest core defense
possible by the left-wing media whenever
they say that they actually care about
children you should remember this
particular thing because it's pretty
pretty astonishing okay
so we'll be back here tomorrow with all
of the latest welcome back to the
workweek gang I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah all Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright ford
publishing 2018